Okay, so, I want to talk about two things on this
little slide, here. The first one is kind of a general
observation about rewards and what makes the reinforcement learning MDP problem
different from the supervised learning problems that we did before. And
that's the notion of not just rewards, but this notion
of delayed rewards. So, what do I mean by that. Well,
so, if you think about the way we've set up kind
of problem like, like we have here where we're trying to.
Start in this little bottom left-hand square, and wind
our way up into this plus one. There's really
this notion of sequences of action. So in the
reinforcement learning context, and all the things that we're talking
about, at least in the foreseeable future, there's this
sort of problem where you take some action and
that puts you in some place and then you
take another action and that puts you in some place.
And then you take another action and that puts you in some place
and maybe it puts you at a place where you get plus one.
Or maybe it puts you at a place where you get minus one.
And what really is going on here is this idea that you take
actions that will set you up for other actions that will set you
up for other actions. And only then do you know how good those
particular actions you took were. So this reward is not just an idea
of getting a reward at every state, it's an idea of getting delayed reward.
So you don't know how your immediate action
is going to lead to things down the road.
So, let me give you a concrete example
about that. So, have you ever played chess?
>> Sure.
>> So let's say we played a long game
of chess and maybe took 60, 61, 62 moves. And
then at the end, I win the game. So, what
do you know about the way you played that game?
>> That I probably made a bad decision around
the time when I decided to play chess against you.
>> That's possible, but maybe you made a
good decision and you kept making good decisions, and
you only messed up at the very last move,
when you could have mated me but you didn't.
>> I see. Well you, what, my
experience in playing chess is that usually, that's
not what happens. Usually it's not that I make a bad move and then there's
a problem. It's usually I make a move that I think is reasonable that only
later I discover put me in a position where I can't possibly do anything good.
>> Right. Well that's actually
the game that I played in New York many,
many years ago that I lost was exactly like that.
The game went on for like literally a hundred
moves. I really lost the game on the third move.
>> Oh.
>> I made a mistake, i transposed two moves because it was a new
opening that I was just learning and I knew at the time that i screwed
up, i played beautiful chess from that point on, but the truth is the
other player had a positional advantage from
that point on that I could never overcome,
so I lost the game, but not because I played poorly for,
you know, 80 moves. It's because I paid, played poorly for one
move, and that move happened to be fairly early. So this is
this notion of delayed reward, that I played this long game of
chess, and maybe it's I played well, and I screwed up in
the end. Maybe I played medio, you know, mediocre game, but I
had a couple of brilliant moves, and that's why I won, or
maybe I played very well in the beginning, poorly at the end or
the other way around. And the truth is you don't
really know. All you know is that you're taking a bunch
of actions. You get rewards signals back from the environment. Like
I won the game or I lost the game. And then
you have this problem of figuring out of all the actions
that I took, what was the action that led to me
ultimately winning or losing, or getting whatever reward that I, I
got at the end of a sequence. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah it seems like that could
be really challenging. You probably need your
own like sportscaster listening and, and commenting.
>> Yeah and in fact the sportscaster who is listening and commenting
at least in the NDP world is in fact the sequence of rewards
that you get in the sequence of states that you see right?
It really is sort of a play by play. In this state this
action got this reward and you want to take all of that
and figure out whether this was a good action you're first action or
a poor action or your second action was good or poor and so
on and so forth. Now contrast that with supervised learning, so in supervised
learning what you would be getting is while I was in this state This
first date and then this was the proper action I was supposed to take
let's say action seventeen. And your goal then is just to simply learn a
function from states to specific actions, that's
how the supervised learning problem is setup, right?
>> Yeah exactly.
>> In this particular case you're in some
state you take some action and you get
some reward for the action you took. Or may be the state that you ended up
in or something. And you get a sequence of these
state action award triples, and ultimately you have to figure out
for the given states you're in, what was the action
you took that helped to deter, or actions you took that
helped to determine the ultimate sequence of rewards that you
saw. Perhaps this one plus one or this minus one that
you got at the end. This is really difficult problem,
its got its own name, its called the credit assignment problem.
In fact, we're talking about a sequence
of events over time, we typically refer to
this type of problem as the temporal
credit assignment problem. Does that make sense Michael.
>> Yeah that's really cool. Although I guess its credit but also blame right?
>> Well credit and blame you know, blame is just the minus of credit.
So without loss of generality Assume that
credit can assume a negative or positive vibe.
>> And yet when I go to the supermarket they never say blame or credit.
>> Well that's just because they don't understand
the technical terms.
>> Got it.